depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant il
y a une bataille très intense qui
continue à backgroute ou comme vous avez
dit c'est le seul endroit où les Russes
sont vraiment dans une position
offensive mais est-ce qu'il progresse
difficile à dire s'il progresse c'est de
quelque kilomètres seulement et après
avec des nouveaux succès pour les
Ukrainiens qui les repoussent ils
avaient pris les Russes d'après nos
informations le contrôle de l'important
carrefour à la sortie de Batman sur la
route qui mène vers le nord vers
crématorze qui est la plus grande ville
dont le don-basse tenu par les
Ukrainiens en ce moment mais ensuite les
Ukrainiens ont affirmé avoir repris le
contrôle de ce carrefour ce sont bien
sûr des informations difficiles à
confirmer indépendamment sans avoir
accès sur place mais l'impression qu'on
a c'est que il y a des pertes très
importantes des deux côtés sans que les
russes arrivent toutefois à prendre le
contrôle de cette ville importante qui
est backmout il semblerait que c'est
surtout tous les forces des mercenaires
de Wagner tenus par Yves Kenny Prigogine
qui sont déployés pour cette offensif
russe vers backmouth ce qui laisse
spéculer si ce n'est pas en réalité une
sorte de bataille entre priscogie et
Poutine une rivalité entre priscogyne et
Poutine qui est derrière cet acharnement
a essayé de prendre backmouth parce que
c'est peut-être Wagner qui a envie de
démontrer sa supériorité par rapport aux
forces confessionnelles de l'armée russe
qui est en retrait sur les autres font
et pourquoi volody merzelens qui dit que
c'est offensive verbackmouth et est une
folie c'est parce que il n'y a pas
d'offensif correspondante vont venant
depuis une autre direction depuis le
nord pour essayer de prendre les villes
clés du don-best tenu par lucre par
l'Ukraine puisque après que l'Ukraine a
pris le contrôle de l'imam les Russes
ont complètement cessé d'attaquer depuis
le nord